CNN learning
exclusively about a new CIA campaign.
And this one is aimed
at recruiting Russians
to spy for the United States.
Our Alex Marquardt
obtaining remarkable video from the CIA
with their message
intended to lure Russians
and turn them against Putin.
It is a story you'll see.
First, OUTFRONT
will
at the television shattering image, tough
to beat, notoriously difficult
questions being asked in Russian.
And a new dramatic video
by the CIA
just released to try to recruit
more Russian spies
by appealing to Russians
patriotism, frustrations
and the oppression they face.
Under the Putin regime.
CIA officials told CNN
in an exclusive interview
that the war in Ukraine
has created an unprecedented opportunity
that they want to capitalize
on to recruit new Russian assets.
Disaffection with the war
will continue
to nor away at the Russian leadership.
Beneath the steady diet of state
propaganda and practiced repression
in the past year of the war,
the CIA has been encouraging Russians
with valuable information
to contact them quietly, securely
and anonymously
through a portal on the dark web.
We're looking around the world
for Russians
who are is disgusted with that is we are
because we're open for business.
Instructions have been posted
on the CIA's social media accounts.
And this new video,
after making an emotional pitch
to Russian viewers.
Details how to do that
using the dark web browser called Tor.
You're not powerless.
It says Contact us in a safe way.
The CIA recruitment video
was first posted
Monday evening on Telegram.
The social media app
that is highly popular among Russians
who can't easily access
unfiltered news
or other social media sites that call it
hanging out the shingle
and spreading the word far and wide
that U.S.
and counterintelligence
is open for business.
And we have deep pockets
and we want to strike
back against this man.
You hate Vladimir Putin.
You have an opportunity now to do it
safely.
CIA officials told CNN they hope
the video will resonate
beyond intelligence
and security officials
with people
who may not realize
that they have sensitive information
to share working, for example,
in cyber tech, finance and other fields.
They may think contacting the CIA
is too difficult or too dangerous.
The CIA telling CNN
they want to demystify that.
We need people
all through the Russian economy
to cooperate with us.
We need to know what's going on
in this adversary country.
There is no direct mention
of Putin
or Ukraine, nor CIA officials insist.
Is it meant to fuel unrest in Russia?
Rather, they tell CNN
these are timeless themes
that they hope
will drive Russians
into the arms of the CIA
at the double get money out of Syria.
Every state
messenger, every state
read the story.
A good idea.
My name is
in terms of what
the CIA has already seen
and their efforts to recruit
new Russian spies during this war.
They say they have been successful.
One CIA official told me, in his words,
there's contact coming in now, Aaron.
They won't give any numbers
or say where these Russians work,
but the CIA says
they wouldn't
be rolling out this new video
if they hadn't already had some success.
We should also note
that the FBI has tried
recruiting Russian spies
right here in Washington
with ads
specifically targeted at people
coming and going
from the Russian embassy,
an effort that the embassy called
ridiculous Aaron.
Alex, thank you very much.
It is important in that context, though,
just a note to everybody.
There are a lot of
Russians who are coming and
going out of the United States
that that is still the reality.
All right.
OUTFRONT now, Elina Polyakov, us,
she is a Russian foreign affairs expert
and the president
and CEO of the Center for European
Policy Analysis.
So, Elina,
as you hear these recruitment videos,
which just to be clear,
are going out on Telegram
as Alex is reporting.
That is a place
where Russians spend a lot of time.
That is the social media,
the predominant social media in Russia.
So what do you hear
when you hear these videos
and the appeal
that they're making to retain
your dignity,
to take care of your family?
I mean, hearing the Russian language
is being spoken in these videos just now,
I think it's absolutely brilliant.
Honestly, there are so many Russians
that we will never, ever hear from
who are disappointed
with the future
they see ahead of them,
which is a very, very bleak future
under President Putin.
And we'll never hear them
talk about this publicly
because people in Russia
are really deeply afraid
of the kind of punishment
that might come with saying
anything in public.
You know, let's remember,
this is a country
that will throw you in jail
for holding up a white sheet of paper
with no words on it.
So I think this is an absolutely
brilliant ploy by the CIA
to see if we can get some informants
average people
to cooperate with the United States.
Now, Olena,
you heard what Alex is reporting.
He's saying the CIA knows that
in a sense
that they return on investment,
that they're doing this
because they
and they are having contacts already
coming in.
Do you think to this point
about the risks
that the Russians are speaking to
or inside Russia
who may see this,
that this dark Web browser
that going to tour,
that this is something that
the people would take any enough people,
I guess, would take a risk on
Well, it's very hard
to strike the right tone.
You know, the kind of message
that we just heard in
the segment
is not going to appeal to everyone.
Some people are going to laugh it off,
but presumably
they get things out of cooperating
with the intelligence services.
This they might get some payments.
They might get security.
You know,
these are things that Russians
many Russians
are really craving right now.
So there is a certain appeal there.
Is it
going to reach a large number of people?
We don't know.
But I think the CIA
is probably counting on the fact that
even if it reaches
a few dozen who take the necessary steps
and who feel comfortable doing that,
that's already a win.
And Lina, one further question.
Alex was talking about the FBI
trying to recruit
people come
and going from the Russian embassy.
And it does make you realize
there are a lot of people
who who do find ways
to come and go from Russia
in and out of the United States
that are here completely legally,
that they're able to do that.
There are Russians
also come
and go from other places
in large numbers,
maybe, you know,
places in the United Arab
Emirates, for example.
Do you think that there's been success
in recruiting among that group?
Again, it's hard to know.
We don't know what
the intelligence agencies are doing.
They're not going to share
that kind of information with us.
But of course,
there are many many Russians
who are still coming to the United States
as tourists.
It's not easy to get a tourist visa.
Of course, for most Russians,
but those who have the
the money
and the wealth to travel
to go to a different country
besides Russia, to get their visas,
basically impossible
to get a visa to the United States
in Russia today.
But look, you
if you have a visa to go to Germany
or Estonia, it's
probably not that hard for you
if you're willing to to wait it out.
So I think certainly
there's huge opportunities here.
We know
that many, many Russians,
especially those that are more well-off
who are in the middle
class, you know,
who want a different kind of life
for themselves,
you know, are going to come to the US
and they want to live like Westerners.
They don't want to live
in an oppressive society
with a bleak future.
All right.
Thank you very much. I appreciate it.
Thank you.